i think that the idea of perfectionism
the idea of getting it right
the idea of like having a messy
conversation perfectly is like
well that that's nearly impossible
especially for
white folks that haven't handled race
the same way and have
lived a pretty easy life here in these
united states like
to to think that like we're going to
step into an arena and like
get it all right like there will be
missteps on this trip
and in these conversations and on my
side and like you know one of the things
that
one of the uh equity advisors for
november project told me today was like
acknowledge at the top acknowledge at
the top of the show and you sort of did
it but i'll do it again for myself for
both of us like
what if you're launching into a
conversation where you're going to make
mistakes like like not like
oh if we have a mistake on these topics
and i don't even know which ones we'll
cover but like
if we have one then we'll no no
let's just assume we're going to make
mistakes because you and i are both new
to this
like it's embarrassing right but it's
probably better to proceed going towards
some mistakes but
in the right direction then like let's
freeze up until
you know when you get all you get all
rigid you can totally say the right
thing
and then the conversation really doesn't
end up going anywhere right because
you're
you're you're coming from a place of
fear and there's one thing that i've
kind of learned
or gleaned from conversations that i've
had over the last
12 months on this subject
it's that um it's exactly what you said
like you can't be afraid to have the
conversation right acknowledging you're
not going to get it perfectly
i think there's a there is a trepidation
with
a lot of white people they want to talk
about it but but that fear prevents them
from even having the conversation yep
because they don't want to get it wrong
they don't want to get castigated for
saying the wrong thing
and so those conversations never
transpire yep and then and then
those out there that are like yeah i
wanna yeah
okay i'm gonna do the reading and i'm
gonna i'm gonna get it right and i'm
gonna figure it out
and then i'm gonna engage and they
engage and they engage and they get it
wrong
and they get called out or or called a
racist or critiqued or
and then and then the white fragility of
flares like like i'm you know i'm trying
why are you taking me down but it's not
the responsibility right of the black
community to give you a pat on the back
and say good job
right and if we're living this like
insular like existence of like
of of white privilege that puts you in a
place where like
you've you know you've practiced your
whole life not taking criticism and so
it really like it doubly hurts it's ten
times i'm not used to this it's like
well well well you should enter into
these enter the real world a little bit
you know and
and uh look it sounds as if i'm like
coming from a place of experience
i am when it comes to messing up you
know like when it comes to doing the
wrong things and
and uh proceeding you know as if i
i i know the whole picture but it's it's
the way i've looked at
you know building community and the way
i looked at november project has been
through
the lens of of who i am and running of
who i am and it was in boston
and kind of how i i saw bringing a group
together and how to supercharge a group
and and so
you know i i don't take credit of
responsibility for
for all of november project but i think
it was um
it was built by two white guys and and i
think there's another thing that you
know so me and i spoke about today is
like
for my for my white friends out there
that look at november project and just
say
that's fun it's just fun you know it's
it's not racist it's
it's just it's a free community thing
like people should show up if they can
and if they can't they can't and it's
it's for everyone and it's just it's
good
i would say um
it was comfortable for us we chose
locations for us and we chose
um to to to bring people together in the
only way we knew how
and we did it with with our language and
our social media and and
um the group is as uh
is formed by two cisgendered white guys
two rowers
in boston like uh
fancy school pedigree and when i when
i'm having the beginning of this story
and i can tell it's not landing i say
could could two black men have could two
shirtless black men have gone into the
harvard
stadium and built a group of three four
five hundred people
that were screaming and and uh
and and you know waking up the
neighborhood with
booming [ __ ] yeahs and like hugging it
out and just having the best time
and uh you know what would that look
like like what
how would that have looked i'm not
talking about harvard university i'm not
talking about
boston police department i'm not talking
about the neighbors in in the in the
residing areas i'm talking about
all of it and and um and i
and i think that kind of helps frame it
as far as like the be
from from the beginning we were
operating with white privilege is the
harvard stadium open to train in well
it's open
mm-hmm so we go in and we make it our
home
and that's a very privileged way of
operating yeah
you know that's a super interesting
perspective on it i mean that that takes
a lot of maturity to kind of own that
aspect of it because
it is easy and on some level you could
make the argument correct
to just say look we just we put this
thing together and anybody can come like
there's no
there's no closed doors to anybody but
to
step back and and really objectively
deconstruct that from
a systemic perspective to kind of own
that
um i imagine that took some work to get
to that place
and then then of course the question
becomes where do you go from there right
like how do you
not just say that you did anything wrong
but
acknowledging that you could do better
like what are the steps you put in place
because it is all about community
community is the
bread and butter of the whole november
project that's the ethos
of it so how do you how do you how do
you like broaden that aperture
to make it more welcoming to all comers
i think even just laying out that that
context of like
what what it is who it's for and i think
um
community members and leaders people who
have been once people who are diehards
like
if we can't see that access that we've
had
if we can't see you know one of my
favorite
stories from the boston days was like
this police officer came and told us
never to come back to this hill again
and i i i assured him we would
seven exactly seven days from then and i
i'm like talking to this guy with no
shirt on like just barely respectful but
like
kind of having fun with the conversation
and he said you know if
i'm going to write you a warning today
and if you come back it's going to be
too
couple hundred dollar ticket because
it's too loud or
yeah well yeah so he said neighbors have
complained and i said i don't think that
they have and he goes well
you know it's a sound or ordinance
violent violation and i was like wow
i'm gonna i'm gonna work on that and
he's like well just don't come back and
i said i'll see you
seven days from now and this defiant
nature of like
like how you know the coolness of like
being kind of just rad and like
laugh in the face of authority like i i
need our community to see that that's
how we built this like i need i don't
know a community like look at that as
white privilege and if like
if you don't want to come along on that
ride like that's going to be hard
but your question was like how do you go
about and change that
you can't change the origin story but
acknowledging that
had that been a black dude you know
having that confrontation with a cop
it would have been a very different
outcome and i think i think
i agree and i think the people that um
can watch the news and see black and
brown people being killed
for traffic violations
and then play back that story i just
told you
you got it we got to see that difference
and so
um i'm i'm really lucky to be part of
this tuesday night group called white
men for racial justice and it's like a
hundred dudes that jump back we're
supposed to
talk about that i'm gonna mention it but
then move on and um the reason i brought
it up is because every wednesday morning
then i go to november project and so
like i'm kind of waking up fresh off of
this
this last conversation before i went to
bed before i got back with the community
in november project
um and one of the conversations about
this this groundwater theory and
like how racism is in everything
and and i think when people want to
solve things quickly
and figure out how to make things right
overnight
you come to this like barrier of
frustration and and i think
i think that's that's like the um that's
the first reaction of like how are we
gonna fix this how we're gonna fix
november project you know can november
project dismantle white supremacy
and and you laugh but it's like
uh i think that dismantling white
supremacy happens in small spaces
times a million right so if we can make
small changes
with
the location that we host a workout what
does it mean to choose something in
dallas or in orlando or in london that's
quote unquote centrally located
what does that mean um centrally by
whose definition
right yeah yeah i mean social media is
such a toxic place right now but i saw
something i thought was really great
which is like
this idea of um there's a big difference
the line was there's a big difference
between
um all our welcome and this was built
with you in mind and um
i just thought it was super powerful
like we were
guilt tripping half the city of like oh
you can get there get there but we were
really just talking to
white folks we were connected to yeah
there seems to be this tension between
or this internal tension uh
with white people on the one hand this
desire to participate in the solution
but also a cautiousness like is this
really my place this is this
you know is it appropriate for me to
participate
in this or is that like going to come
across
as you know come across in the wrong way
frankly and i think that creates a lot
of paralysis
participate in this meaning in in you
know in the progressive movement towards
change
yeah um
it's it's fine it's when you say that i
i am
i always looked at uh friends of mine or
co-leaders uh who i would consider
activists especially
white folks that i saw wearing blm
clothing
and i always like thought that they were
they'd done all the reading
and that they were like they were in it
and they were like must have been
experts
or like you know they had they had they
had voted the right way and
given their money there and were a
mentor and and also knew
all the policies and they're really
fighting the fight every minute of every
day and they've been at it for years and
um and this idea of
starting somewhere like um
one of our leaders in um in kansas city
nicole i really admire her she's like
just always boots on the ground always
having these conversations always
uh challenging white folks in her life
and having conversations
like um but she's always wearing plm
gear
and i always looked at her and like i
admired her and it was almost like she's
on the varsity team
like she's she's an anti-racist but i
gotta read a couple more books or like
i'm not there yet and um i've had
friends in my life recently just be like
no you have to you just you have to
start if it's signaling with a yard sign
if it's a hooded sweatshirt if it's
donating if it's
the training that you're doing with
november project co-leaders um
you know just continuing education but
then you have to go out and have these
conversations you have to go out and
participate
and build meaningful relationships and
um
so anyway i just i find i find the um
the bummer of a challenge is getting
folks to take a step
to start something you know and it was
so easy for me to talk about that when i
was talking about fitness
right and it was so easy for us to
figure out diversity and how to bring
different kinds of athletes along
right like that was a really easy one
for us to talk about but
um a lot of people especially white
people
freeze up when it comes to like i don't
know where to begin
and and what about uh what about the
person who doesn't want to begin
like you must have people in your life
who really don't want to engage with
this certainly not at the level that
you've
that you've been engaging with it yeah
um so
um i'll give you my answer from for
for me i i've always said and i said
this to you back when we met
years ago which is like i give people
out a lot of chances and and
how that shows up in these conversations
is that i'll meet someone where they are
you know i'll have a whatever pace
conversation you need to have uh i'll
politely try and debunk
and explain and understand where your
positioning is and
and uh and meet people wherever they are
on the road
right if someone says there is no
problem
if someone says race isn't a thing
[Music]
i i think that's really a hard place to
start
right but um you know one of the
six community agreements for november
project is this idea of calling people
in
and um it sounds so like gentle and a
little bit hippie of like
don't call people out rich that's too
messy call them in
but there really is some truth to it
which is like if you call someone out
say well that sounds racist i think
you're racist
like how much could you even repair that
yeah relationship conversation like
ended any opportunity for moving the
needle and you've destroyed your
relationship with that person
right and so to to learn more to learn
more to ask more questions and
and and understand where they're coming
from
i mean that process takes a long time it
takes patience and and if someone were
to
say i'm not here for that i'm cutting
that person out of my life
um i also understand that for them but i
i recognize sometimes with with white
people in my life i can make change by
saying tell me more about that
so
[Music]
you